Bad Bunny's 2026 halftime show at the
NFL Super Bowl show was nothing more
than a predictive programming ritual
telling you that the antichrist is soon
to come. This is what they have to do.
These people, they have to put the truth
right in front of your face. This is
cabalism. And part of their belief is
that they have to show you. They have to
get your consent before they perform
their act. What you're going to see
isnosticism. A lot of people were
looking for blatantly overt satanic
symbols and there wasn't a lot of that
in this performance that I saw. I only
saw the literally just the halftime show
with Bad Bunny and Lady Gaga. And I do
believe that there is a reason why they
didn't get so blatantly occultic in this
halftime show.
Because for years the rulers of this
world, Satan, the god of this world, who
we battle not against flesh and blood,
but against principalities, against the
powers of the darkness of this world,
have been creating the chaos so that
they can bring in the order. And so part
of the chaos is not just wars and quote
unquote natural disasters, but also
blatant satanic rituals on stage.
Epstein files coming out, Diddy files
coming out, Nickelodeon uh behind the
scenes coming out, all of this stuff is
coming out strategically right now
because the quote unquote dystopian
order is coming, the new world order.
Sonosticism, you see Adam and Eve here
in the garden. And what did the serpent
say to the woman in Genesis 3:5? He
said, "For God doth know that the in the
day that you eat thereof, your eyes
shall be open, and you shall be as gods,
knowing good and evil." So,nosticism
is the belief that Satan or Lucifer was
a good angel who entered into the garden
that God created this perfect garden
prison where Adam and Eve had to be
bound in. And he's this tyrannical
villain that didn't want them to have
knowledge. And that he was keeping them
from knowledge by saying, "Do not eat of
this fruit." And Lucifer came in and
said, "God doesn't want you to know. He
doesn't want you to have eyes to see. He
doesn't want you to know that you are
God and can evolve to godhood." And so
this is whatnosticism teaches and you'll
see it over and over in Hollywood and in
these performances. And so this Super
Bowl halftime show started out showing
the apple, the bit apple, and it zooms
into this awakening state of having your
eyes open, this transcendence from the
physical to the spirit world,
e evolving into godhood. That's what
this whole translike portal was all
about.
Gnosticism
teaches that when you eat this fruit,
that's salvation. It says uniquely, the
gnostic religion held that the tree was
entirely positive or even sacred. And
then down here, it says this savior does
so by telling Adam and Eve that eating
the fruit is the way into salvation. So
when it shows the fruit and it shows the
awakening portal, it's their salvation.
Eating the fruit brings knowledge.
Eating the fruit brings godlyhood,
awakening, evolving into God literally.
And so here we see a scene of what? We
see a harvest. We see people in white
harvesting a crop. This is very
symbolic. The Bible is full of symbols.
You hear about, you know, a bride and a
beast and all these things. And Jesus
talked about the harvest. Here you see a
up close view of these people in white
harvesting. So it's harvest time. This
is very crazy to have a scene like this
on a football field. I mean this took a
lot of work to put these crops of
whatever this is. I don't know if this I
think these are uh coconut trees or
something. But they're harvesting right
here on the football field. And Matthew
9:37-38
says, "Then saith he unto his disciples,
the harvest truly is plenteous,
but the laborers are few. Pray ye there
therefore the Lord of the harvest that
he will send forth laborers into his
harvest." What is Jesus talking about?
He's talking about in the end of the
world, in the end of the world, there's
going to be people who are ready to be
harvested, but he needs workers to go
out there and sew the seed of the
gospel. And in Matthew 13:39, it says
the harvest is the end of the world. And
the reapers are the angels. So keep keep
a checklist of what we're seeing. We're
seeing people in white, the angels.
We're seeing harvesting. And what is
harvesting? The end of the world. This
is a repetitious pattern in this
predictive programming uh ritual that
they did on on live television for
everyone. And then you see Bad Bunny
here and he's wearing all white. Even
the numbers on his jersey are written in
white, but you can see that it's the
number 64. What is the number 64 in the
occult? In numerology, the number 64
holds significant occult tantric and
metaphysical meaning. also a symbol of
absolute totality, structural perfection
and the manifestation of divine energy.
So this is talking about manifesting,
bringing something into this physical
world, divine godlyhood, divine godly
energy manifest into this world. And
then you see down the next underline, it
says divine feminine. This is all what's
happening in these last days. We've seen
a big push towards the divine feminine
over and over. You're going to see that.
Um Chris Bledsoe talking about seeing
the lady and oh it's over and over. I
mean uh Katy Perry was talking about the
divine feminine when she went up in the
rocket over and over. It mentions Shiva
which we hear a lot about because of
CERN and it's talking about symbolizing
complete mastery of arts and
consciousness. So 45 or 64 is all about
consciousness, divine energy,
manifestation and divine order and
completion. What order? The new world
order. And it says new beginnings,
stability, and divine order. Because
there's been so much chaos that the
world is primed and ready. The stage is
set for us to desire and crave order.
even if it's from Satan himself bringing
about peace and safety as the Bible says
that the antichrist will come bringing
about peace and safety. Now, here you
see that Bad Bunny has a tattoo, uh, an
interesting tattoo. Not only the monarch
mind control butterfly, um, among other
things, a crucifix on his neck, uh,
right on his chest, but because that we
just looked at divine feminine and how
this is all about reaching a higher
state of consciousness, this logo right
here, this symbol is a male and female
together. This is the reebus
and in esoteric
belief systems
in order to reach perfect godhood. In
order to reach higher consciousness and
to reach the Christ consciousness, to
reach the highest level of godliness,
you have to become
neither male nor female or both like the
baffomet being male and female. And
you'll see in the hands of this Reebis
character, the compass and the square
just like the Freemasons.
And the goal of the great work, the
reebus is the final perfect product of
alchemical transmutation, symbolizing
the harmonious resolution of inner and
outer conflicts. Symbol of perfection,
to be a hermaphrodite, to be both male
and female or neither, non-binary, all
this stuff. That is when you've reached
divine perfection. Often portrayed
holding a compass which represents
spirit and a square which represents
matter while standing on a dragon. It
represents a harmonious perfected state
of existence. He has this tattooed right
on his chest. Why? Because he literally
is
portraying to be a woman, to be male and
female openly in his music videos.
um just straight up drag, trans, all
this. So, he is the next puppet for the
Illuminati. He's the one that is taking
the stage right now on his performance
at at the event where all the nation is
watching. The most eyes are on this
event. That's why these um big major
corporations will spend thousands and
millions of dollars to get this short ad
on this at the Super Bowl because so
many eyes are on it. And this is where
they, you know, initiate people and and
Lady Gaga was here to initiate Bad Bunny
as the next puppet to bring about the
agenda.
And as he's walking, this is like a a
one take camera shot thing. He's walking
and things are happening. Different
scenes are happening. And I just noticed
that there was a pattern. I said, "Wait
a minute. He's there's eating,
drinking,
and giving in marriage." This is what
made me think about it. Eating and
drinking. Maybe I would have looked past
it. But when I saw why is there suddenly
a proposal? It makes no sense. He's
walking by. He walks past the taco
stand. He walks past the drink stand.
And then suddenly somebody's proposing.
They're eating and drinking and giving
in marriage. This is what Matthew 24,
which is all about the last days.
Matthew 24:38 talks about for as in the
days of Noah were before the flood, they
were eating and drinking and marrying
and giving in marriage until the day
that Noah entered into the ark.
So it it's talking about when Christ
returns, it's going to be just the same.
the the state of humanity. The state of
the world is going to be just like the
days of Noah. People aren't even
expecting this disaster to come. They're
not expecting Christ's return. They
weren't expecting the floodwaters to
come. They were eating and drinking,
giving marriage and life as usual. And
they literally showed it step by step in
this performance.
Then Bad Bunny walks by these women who
really aren't building anything. And it
looks like they're starting to build a
wall. But as you see, she has this
shovel in her hand. I'm not exactly sure
what the name of that is. It's a Masonic
shovel where you spread out concrete to
lay the bricks. And you can see it in
all the Masonic imagery. And so this is
a nod to the Freemasons. This is a nod
to who Bad Bunny works for.
And here you see everybody dressed in
white, but they are acting very
promiscuous. And at the beginning, you
see these people looking up into the
sky. All of this is symbolic. Why are
they all dressed in white? Revelation
7:13-14 says, "And one of the elders
answered, saying unto me, what are these
which are arrayed in white robes? And
whence came they? And I said unto him,
Sir, thou knowest?" And he said to me,
"These are they which came out of the
great tribulation, and have washed their
robes, and made them white in the blood
of the lamb." Now, I don't want people
to get confused on what's going on here.
Yes, this predictive programming that is
happening right before our eyes is
telling the story of Revelation, but
it's not in a good way. This isn't like
we're watching some Christian
performance about the Bible. This is a
twist. This is a Gnostic flip to where
the worldly and the promiscuous, they're
the ones, including Cardi B, they're the
ones who are dressed in white. They're
the ones who are awaiting their Messiah.
They're the ones who are eating and
drinking and giving in marriage. But are
they going to be destroyed or are they
going to be saved by this savior that's
coming in this uh predictive programming
ritual? Here
you can see Bad Bunny is on top of a
building that is a perfect square, a
perfect cube. That is not usual when you
see buildings. They're not usually a
perfect cube. Usually they're a
rectangle or an unusual shape. But to
see this perfect cube caught my
attention, especially with this gold
glowing edge around it, it made me think
of when Christ returns, he's coming in
the cities bringing the new Jerusalem
with him to the earth with his angels.
And you see that he has six dancers
dressed in white. This is an
illustration or a symbolic of Bad Bunny
being the savior coming to Earth. Right
now, he's still in the cube city, but he
is coming to save the world from all the
chaos.
And you'll see he goes to the edge and
all these people are in white. They're
raising their hands up to him and
worship. Again, though, these are the
angels. They're in white.
And here he falls through the roof into
somebody's home. Notice these aren't
people dressed in white. These are
people who are caught off guard. They
don't know what just happened. This
messianic figure, this Antichrist figure
has just fallen into their home like a
thief. They They were taken off guard.
They didn't know what happened. He broke
into their home. And 1 Thessalonians 5:2
says, "For yourselves know perfectly
that the day of the Lord so cometh as a
thief in the night."
2 Peter 2 or 2 Peter 3:10 says, "But the
day of the Lord will come as a thief in
the night, in the which the heavens
shall pass away with a great noise, and
the elements shall melt with fervent
heat, and the earth the earth also and
the works that are therein shall be
burned up."
Revelation 3:3 says, "Remember therefore
how thou hast received and heard and
hold fast and repent." Notice this is
this is not bringing about repentance at
all. There's no message of repentance at
all in this performance that's playing
out. If therefore thou shalt not watch,
I will come on thee as a thief, and thou
shalt not know what hour I will come
upon thee. Now, these people clearly did
not expect him. When he came as a thief
into their home, they were shocked. So,
they will not be saved according to the
truth. But according to this
performance, they will be saved. Because
when the false Messiah, when Satan
appears as Christ, many are going to
embrace him. He's going to bring about
peace. He's going to be doing lying,
signs, and wonders, miracle working
demons. People are going to believe that
he is Christ. And yet, in their sin,
they weren't destroyed.
He didn't come upon them as a thief and
they got destroyed. They are actually
still alive.
Revelation 16:15 says, "Behold, I come
as a thief. Blessed is he that watcheth
and keepeth his garments, lest he
walketh naked, and they see his shame."
So here now we see that it's not the
angels because now he has descended to
earth. Now he's come like a thief and
now all these people who clearly are not
dressed in white, they're not in white
robes. They are just worldly secular
people. They're worshiping him. They're
not destroyed. They're actually saved
because their Messiah has come. But he's
representing the antichrist because
anyone who looks like Christ or follows
um you know the same kind of pattern as
Christ but doesn't have the same mission
as Christ to bring repentance is what is
antichrist.
This is not Christ but he's doing all
the things that Christ would do. He's
reaping the harvest. He's coming at a
time when people are eating and drinking
and giving in marriage. and he comes
like a thief in the night as he descends
from the cube, the golden cube with his
angels.
He is not Christ, he's antichrist.
And here you'll see him look up into the
sky at a frog. Now the symbolism of a
frog and the esoteric meaning of a frog
centers on profound transformation,
cleansing and emotional healing
symbolizing the journey from water
subconscious emotions to land conscious
manifestation representing metamorphosis
from tadpole to adult. It signifies
adapting to change, fostering an
abundance mindset
and embracing spiritual rebirth.
or deep personal growth.
You'll notice if you've watched our if
you've been watching our videos over and
over and over in all the things that
we've been breaking down, it's always
about a spiritual rebirth. a phoenix
rising out of the ashes, the oraoris,
we've seen it with turning point, we've
seen it with the speeches from Erica
Kirk, and now we're seeing it here at
this performance where it's all about
this spiritual rebirth or the reebus or
on and on. We keep seeing the symbolism
of moving from the old order to the new
order, a spiritual
evolution,
transformation, and metamorphosis.
As masters of change, frogs embody the
ability to shed old patterns to get rid
of the old order, adapt to new
environments, and undergo spiritual
evolution. That's what this is all
about.
Limmonality and wisdom living between
water and land. They represent the
bridge between the physical and
spiritual worlds, often acting as
intermediaries
to or protectors of mystical realms.
I don't, you know, I think it's odd that
he looked up at this cartoon frog. I
looked into it. Um, he is some kind of
mascot of Bad Bunny, but I think there's
a reason for that. Nothing is by
accident. Bad Bunny is a puppet. He
every time you see him, he's throwing up
a 666 over his eye or he's got a
allseeing eye in his forehead. He is the
next puppet for the Illuminati right
now.
In Revelation 16:13-14
talks about these frogs. It says, "I saw
three unclean spirits like frogs, for
they are the spirits of devils." So when
he's looking up at that frog, I believe
that he's looking up at the spirits of
devils that are working miracles which
go forth unto the kings of the earth and
of the whole world to gather them to the
battle of the great day of God Almighty.
That's what the antichrist or that's
what Satan appearing as Christ is going
to do. He is going to prepare the world
to fight against the true Christ
because he is appearing as Christ and
he's going to convince everyone that
there's an enemy coming and we need to
fight against this enemy. But it will be
in actuality it will be the world
uniting with demons in a battle against
the second coming of Christ because the
whole world fell for Satan appearing as
Christ as to be the true Christ.
Now, notice it says that he's gathering
all the world. Keep that in your mind
because we're going to see that played
out
here. You see him singing. Look what we
see. Stringed instruments playing and a
wedding.
Stringed instruments are playing and a
wedding happens. And Revelation 19:7
says, "Let us be glad and rejoice and
give honor to him for the marriage of
the lamb is come and his wife hath made
herself ready." So just like in the book
of Revelation, there's the harpers
harping on their harps and there's this
wedding. This is a counterfeit. We're
what we are seeing right now is
literally a playbyplay of revelation
except it's it's showing people not
repentant but
doing all kinds of debaucherous things
including drinking alcohol and gambling
and being promiscuous and they're not
being destroyed when he comes as a
thief. They're being saved. They're
being preserved and he is their Messiah.
This is because it's not Christ, but he
is the Antichrist. Right after the
wedding, we see Lady Gaga
who is singing a song called Die with a
Smile. And I just think this
interesting. Why would you choose this
song? Where everything we've been
saying, the harvest is the end of the
world. Right? Then she sings a song
where she says, "Wherever you go, that's
where I'll follow." When you read
Revelation, it talks about that those
who follow the lamb wherever he goes,
those are the ones who will be saved.
Those who follow the lamb wherever he
goes. But who is Lady Gaga talking
about? She's not talking about the lamb.
Nobody's promised tomorrow. So, I'm
going to love you every night like it's
the last night. Like it's the last
night. We just saw the beginning of this
was the harvest and the harvest is the
end of the world. Now, she's saying it's
the last night. And then she goes deeper
by saying, "If the world was ending, I'd
want to be next to you. If the world was
over, our time on earth was through, I'd
want to hold you just for a while and
die with a smile. If the world was
ending, I'd want to be next to you." So,
in these lyrics, she's not saying, "The
world is ending and we're gonna we're
going to go on living into the new
world, into the new earth."
She's admitting that we're going to be
lost and I want to and I'm going to die
with a smile because I'm dying in my sin
and I'm going to stay with you till the
end. So, they're putting it right in
your face that the end of the world is
coming. These people know it. The
elitist, the rulers of the world know
because they are ushering in the
Antichrist. So, of course, they know the
end of the world is coming. Once
Antichrist comes, once Satan comes as
Christ, then Christ will come after
that. And they're telling you to your
face, the end of the world is here. But
guess what? You can live in your sin and
die with a smile. Here he is in the
cross pose. And he falls back and
everyone catches him. Again, this is not
the angels dressed in white. These are
the worldly secular people raising their
hands to their savior who's outstretched
in a cross pose.
What do we see here? We see men blowing
horns.
I think it's very interesting
that there are multiple men blowing
horns right now.
One, two, three, four, five, six men
blowing horns.
In the book of Revelation, there are
trumpets. There are seven angels given
seven trumpets and sound them one by
one. These trumpet blasts which occur
after the opening of the seventh seal
act as a warning a herald specific a
herald specific apocalyptic judgments
upon the earth. So not only are these
people telling you in song it's the end
of the world by showing you the harvest
that it's the end of the world by
showing you that he's coming on a a cube
city and he's going to drop in like a
thief in the night. everything they're
telling you, it's the end of the world.
And they even have six
six men blowing horns. Why only six,
though? Because Revelation has seven
sequential judgments. Each angel each
angel's blasts triggers a specific
progressive disaster affecting the
earth, sea, rivers, heaven, and
humanity. Each blast is a plague upon
the earth. But when you read the book of
Revelation, only six of them are
plagues. The last trumpet is what? The
last trumpet is the coming of the true
Christ.
The seventh trumpet, the final seventh
trumpet announces the kingdom of God's
coming. That's why there's only six here
and not seven because they're not
announcing the true coming of Christ.
They're announcing the new world order
that's run by the Antichrist.
But they're giving the the warning.
They're sounding the trumpet blast.
Here you see a family watching TV and
every eye is seeing Bad Bunny. All
around the world on the TV screen they
can see Bad Bunny. Revelation 17 says,
"Behold, he cometh with clouds, and
every eye shall see him."
And then you see him appear and he gives
the the little kid a gift,
an award. Revelation 22:12 says, "And
behold, I come quickly and my reward is
with me." So here's Bad Bunny, the
Antichrist.
Every eye is seeing him. He's rewarding
this child.
And again, in the crucifix pose, this is
not just some accident. It's I didn't
like screen cap him in mid raising his
arms or something. His arms are
outstretched like this for multiple
seconds. He's posing on a pole with two
other people on poles just like Christ.
This is obvious
uh messianic pose here.
And what do we see here? We see people
in white. We see the the the men that
are blowing horns. And the people in
white, they're all above, right? They
represent heaven, what's happening down
on earth. You see all the worldly people
running out. So you see right now, you
see represented heaven and earth.
And you see the antichrist on the pole
in the cross pose proving that he is a
false Christ and everyone on earth is
worshiping him. Everyone in heaven and
earth. You can see in the background,
you can see the the heavenly beings
imitating him. They're acting as Christ.
They're following in his footsteps with
their arms stretched out. You can see
the people on earth doing the same
thing. They are following the beast
wherever he goes.
Revelation 5:13 says, "And every
creature which is in heaven and on
earth, and under the earth, and such are
in the sea, and all that are in them
heard I saying, blessing and honor, and
glory and power be unto him that siteth
upon the throne, and unto the Lamb
forever and ever." This is a false lamb.
And you can see all people represented,
heaven and earth are worshiping him as
he's lifted up.
What do we see in this scene on earth?
We see all nations represented. We see
the flags of all the nations of the
world together, united together,
running towards their Messiah.
Revelation 13:3-4 says, "And all the
world wondered after the beast, and they
worshiped the beast, saying, who is like
unto the beast? Who is able to make war
with him?" This is not just some
coincidence. All of this is adding up.
All the dots are being connected
here. You see, the whole world is
wandering after the beast. They're
following behind him, playing their
instruments, just like the Bible talks
about that there's going to be all these
different instruments being played. And
you see all the nations following behind
him. He's leading in the front. And
there's an interesting sign in the
background. It says, "The only thing
more powerful than hate is love." That
sounds like a beautiful statement. But
if you understand what they believe love
is,
it is not godly.
Godly love is what?
Worshiping God in spirit and in truth.
Loving your neighbor, loving God. All
the ten commandments. The ten
commandments hang on love. That's what
Christ said. All these commandments hang
on loving God and loving your neighbor.
Now, is loving your neighbor, being um,
you know, tolerant and accepting of
their sins? No. It's showing them the
truth and setting them free and giving
them life more abundantly so that they
can have an abundant life and have
eternal life. That's true love. But in
the world's eyes, according to this era
that we live in, love is accepting you
the way you are. Don't judge me. I'm a
homosexual. I'm an alcoholic. I'm an
adulterer. I'm a fornicator. or whatever
it is. I'm a drug addict. You have to
accept me the way I am. That's true love
according to the the ways of this world.
And he is openly a homosexual, openly uh
in drag and all these things. And he is
their leader.
And so I I just asked um Google what is
love just to see what kind of answer I
got because we know that Google is just
this bias machine that's going to give
you the the answer that it wants you to
believe. And it says right here,
acceptance of imperfections.
That's what love is. Accepting people in
their sin. Yes, we need to love the
sinner, but we hate the sin. Just like
Christ, love the sinner, hate the sin.
lead them into truth so that they can be
set free from the bondage and slavery of
sin.
Here you see all the nations of the
world rejoicing and uniting together
with their false Messiah who's dressed
in white who's literally acted out every
scene that Christ is going to do. come
at a time of eating, drinking, giving a
marriage, ascending on a cube city,
coming like a thief in the night.
But instead of bringing death and
destruction to the wicked,
they are actually preserved and live
happily with their false messiah. This
is how we know it's a false messiah.
Because when Christ comes, only the
righteous are going to be saved. We're
going to be caught up to meet the Lord
in the air and the wicked will be
destroyed by the brightness of his
coming. That's why it says that he comes
as a thief in the night. If you're not
watching, if you're not prepared, he
will overtake you like a thief in the
night and you will be destroyed. That is
not shown here.
Repentance is not shown here.
Destruction is not shown here. It's all
about unity under the false Christ. And
here at the end you see him holding a
football towards the camera that says
together we are America.
This is telling you that the superpower
that the United States the superpower of
the world is going to unite together.
It's going to be a a unity a United
Nations a one world
a one world order. A one world religion
a one world currency. We are America,
the beast power who's gonna who's soon
to make laws enforcing worship a false
system of worship which is soon to come.
I hope this made sense to you guys. Hope
it was a blessing. If it was, please
give it a thumbs up. It really helps get
this video out into the algorithm so
more people can see it. If you would
like to support this ministry, you can
do so by going to cantruth.org. We got
Cash App, Vinmo, Zel, PayPal. We even
have Patreon. If you like t-shirts and
mugs and hoodies and different types of
merch like that, we have merch on our
website. We get about $5 per order that
comes through. It really helps this
ministry. Also, if you would like to
invite us to come speak at your event,
your youth group, your schools, your
churches, we do that and we have a way
to book us on our website. And we were
so busy last year. We can't wait to
start this year and see what God has in
store. But we love you. We thank you.
And please share this with your family
and friends so they can see that the end
is near. That they are telling us to our
faces what is soon to come. This is
predictive programming. Don't fall for
it just because it looked somewhat
wholesome this year. Um it wasn't
blatantly occultic for a reason. They're
showing you a lighter side that is going
to convince a lot of people. Oh, this is
all about love and unity and look how
great it was. This is how Satan works.
He's a manipulator and he's going to
unite the world together under the beast
system and he's going to appear as a
counterfeit Christ very soon. All right,
we love you. Thank you. And we will see
you guys next time on Candid Truth.